الاضراب السادس عن الطعام كان الاخير
للاسير خضر عدنان وكان الاطول حيث شارف
على اتمام ثلاثه اشهر متواصله في الاضراب
عن الطعام داخل السجون الاسرائيليه ما في
اي
الاستلام جثمان الشيخ بنرد لكم خبر اذا
كنتم يسلموا لكن احنا كعالي بلغناهم في
وصيه الشيخ عن طريق المحامي انه لا يعني
عدم تشريح جثمان الشهيد وهذه وصيه له
والاصل ان يحترمها وعدم يعني قبولنا باي
تشريح للشيخ اضراب شامل شل كافه مناحي
الحياه في الاراضي الفلسطينيه عقب اعلان
اداره السجون الاسرائيليه عن وفاه الشيخ
خضر عدنان
يحمل مجلس الوزراء الاحتلال واداره سجونه
وكل اجهزته المسؤوليه الكامله عن استشهاد
الشيخ خضر عدنان ونعتبر ذلك جريمه اغتيال
متعمده من خلال رفض طلب الافراج عنه
واهماله طبيا وابقائه في زنزانته رغم
خطوره وضعه وضعه الصحي خضر عدنان البالغ
من العمر 44 عاما قضى منها في السجون
الاسرائيليه ثمان سنوات بشكل متقطع ولديه
من الابناء تسعه خضر عدنان لم يكن اول
اسير يقضي في السجون الاسرائيليه جراء
الاضراب عن الطعام فمن سبقوه قضوا خلال
اضرابات جماعيه لكن خضر عدنان توفي في
اضراب فرديه عن الطعام في السجون
الاسرائيليه من بلده عرابي شمال الاراضي
الفلسطينيه خالد القاسم
العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات